[Music]
a peck season fives here and lobo along
with it I'm here with Jordan hello here
to talk about the newest teleporting
thief she's got a couple tricks up her
sleeve they might not know about and
we're gonna break down her tactical
passive and ultimate as well well let's
get straight into it
how does she work she's got her tactical
which is called burglars bestfriend she
uses her bracelet with something called
a jump drive to teleport to the thrown
bracelets location similar to most
projectile abilities and grenades you
can hold down the button to get the orc
to see worse thrown now you can make
that trip a little bit shorter by
hitting the trigger button in the mid
air it won't teleport you into the air
but it will drop you down on the ground
where you told to stop this tactical has
some nuances to it too from the get-go
when you first pick up Lobo and start
throwing that bracelet around it seems
pretty slow animation wise this
teleporting ability is really slow
startup slow recovery time it's loud
it's very visible and because of this
it's just super punishable from
beginning to end it's really scary to
just throw out there but at the same
time like lava is a support character so
I don't really expect her to have as
quick of a way to get in and out of a
fight as they octane or wraiths so I
understand why people are a little
annoyed by how long it takes for her to
use her tactical but I mean if you use
it more as a supportive method like
trying to get behind someone in the
middle of a fight or like get a higher
ground so that you can age your
teammates by like sniping someone in the
back it's really really good it really
is and like you said like it's mostly
for position advantage and this is not a
panic button you just hit mid fight
because you will die it should be used
behind cover into another covered area
or advantageous area at least but I do
have a couple things that you should
know to keep your survival chances a
little higher well you want to know that
bracelets can be thrown off of zip lines
so it can be a little bit more mobile
you can close doors still so you can get
some extra cover you can jump still it's
a slide still which means you can jump
slide and you can throw in a bunny hop
too so there's just like a couple of
things that just make it a little bit
harder for you to get hit which is
obviously very useful and then also on
the other end this is more for
high-level players but you can cancel
that long recovery by climbing on
wall and then flicking to the next enemy
it seems like half a second which is big
in an apex gunfight and could win you
the gunfight possibly yeah and you do
want to do that like I don't know like
the specifics of like pixel count and
stuff like that but lobha is kind of on
the taller side she's definitely at
least if not taller than Bangalore like
life lane Watson and Wraith all take
more damage so you kind of want to make
MOBA as small as possible you're waiting
for her tactical to get to the spot that
it needs to go because you're not as
tiny as a target as her fellow legends
are yeah in Apex you just want to be as
hard to hit as possible obviously and
any advantage you can make to get your
hitbox harder to hit you should take as
of right now she's a first legend that
can go through windows and door cracks
and other small places this by itself is
probably one of the best things about
her you really think of traversing
buildings in a whole new way situations
like if you're holed up somewhere you
need to get in or you need to get out of
a building that you trapped in its super
clutch I mean it's not working all the
time right now it's at the beginning of
season five but when it does work it's
so satisfying so obviously you have this
tactical ability that allows low but to
cover a lot of ground fairly quickly but
she probably needs some place to go and
that's where her passive comes in I for
quality which allows Loba to see where
purple and gold items are through walls
and even ping them if she's like within
I want to say like 15 to 20 meters you
have to actually be fairly close to ping
stuff through walls but it's still
pretty cool and the fact that you can
just kind of at a glance know where
purple and gold stuff is is most helpful
for me when I'm trying to like outrun
the zone and I'm like I only have a
moment to like see which of these bins I
can open before I have to keep going Hey
yeah it is a huge time-saver instead of
you sifting through all these buildings
looking for the good stuff
unfortunately it's fairly hard to tell
what items are at a distance but at
least you have a general idea of what it
is priority wise to grab first around
you but for the most part it's fairly
straight
or I mean I think really like its best
uses for her ultimate ability like black
market boutique because you can see all
of the gold and purple items that are in
the current range of your ultimate
before you place it down it is a pretty
cool ultimate anything within its
circular radius will just be grab a bowl
for you you throw it on a black market
at that point it's a bit of a startup to
once it actually deploys but then you
can just grab any two items within that
range now a couple of things to note it
is really loud it has a very visible
radius so enemies might come running to
you once you pop that but besides that
it's absolutely worth it because it just
condenses your local loot pool into like
just the best stuff that you want first
which is really really important this
ultimate almost makes it feel like life
lines ultimate is obsolete because it's
like this same essential thing of trying
to get really nice loop but you have a
choice of what you're picking up and you
can use it a lot more quickly than
calling it a lifeline care package
there's just been so many opportunities
where like my teammates and I have just
seen an alt like charge station use it
with lobha because we see like there's a
lot of stuff around and just thrown down
the hall to mediately looted everything
and then just picked up the black market
and gone on our way afterwards like it's
it's so good for outfitting your squad
as quickly as possible a good practice
to have with black market is to
literally close up shop when you're done
because just like revenues totem black
market can be used by enemies too so you
want to wrap it up when you and your
team are done I would say black market
is so good I almost worry that respawn
will nor fit in some capacity in future
updates but for now I'm just enjoying
the ride that it provides I mean its
utilities super cool like two situations
I got was to use it as a portable armor
swap station so I just grabbed two
armors in the middle of a gunfight and
use that to my advantage and it just
worked out perfectly and I won and then
also as a third party steel situation as
well because of black market updates
live any new loot dropped will show up
immediately into a black market so one
time I just stuck around an edge of a
fight drop my ultimate grab your gold
items as they were dying
and just dip down really funny you know
worked out perfectly I was by myself and
there's no way I could have fought them
by myself so I just took all the goodies
left and in those situations black
market is just really nifty yeah as of
right now when it comes to Lobos
weaknesses you should consider a
bracelet one for sure it's a major
blessing and a major curse at the same
time because you're just so vulnerable
on both ends it's just one of those
things one bad throw we'll give an
opposing team like a solid second and a
half of shooting at you before you're
even able to fight back and depending on
what gun they have that could really be
all that they need but besides that
she's not bad at all she has mobility
and access to good loot all the time so
she's really good mm-hmm
that being said she is really good on
her own and she is a good legend to be
on your team but I feel like she doesn't
have any meshed team synergy with other
legends like Kasich Watson mega force or
the crypto Gibraltar stun barrage kind
of thing the only thing I'll strategize
with teammates is to help distract them
in any way so they can close the gap
safely you can use this to pinch your
enemies squads and just use it to great
effect
like you said Lobos just she's just kind
of there to help people get loot which
does help everyone but it's not like oh
if you pair Lobo with wraiths together
like both of them are really good or
something it's like no globe is just
pretty good to play with any of the
other characters so this makes her sort
of hard to place her any sort of tier
but that shouldn't drive your decision
to use her because ignoring any tier
list she's super fun to play and that's
the most important I think and those are
our thoughts on Lobo if you're looking
to keep up with season 5 whether it's
Lobo the new battle paths or the new
story based quest mode be sure to stay
tuned to games
[Music]